wedding plans are underway for Jennifer
Lopez and Alex Rodriguez and we have the
latest on that as the happy couple
shares with us the moment she said yes
JLo looked shocked when a-rod got down
on one knee and the source tells us it
really was a surprise that JLo quote
wasn't to where he'd be proposing on
Saturday hey rod captioned the post
locking it down and hashtag future mrs.
Rodriguez and today we've got a glimpse
into Jay rods wedding plans a source
tells et their kids will play a big part
in their wedding as they were a driving
force in the proposal this will be J
Lo's a fourth wedding this is my husband
Hani Noah JLo married Cuban waiter oh
honey Noah in 1997 they divorced after
less than a year together in 2001 she
married backup dancer Chris Judd
they split after 10 months
JLo's longest marriage was to singer
Marc Anthony they time tonight in 2004
and divorced ten years later of course a
rod has had his share of famous
girlfriends he briefly dated Kate Hudson
in 2009 and the year before that he told
us he was handling rumors of a romance
with Madonna with what else baseball I'd
love to play baseball and to go to a
place for four hours where no one can
get to me if no one can really get into
anything into the personal stuff face
was God saying a rod dated Cameron Diaz
for 16 months starting in 2010 and when
Kevin asked about their relationship a
rod fondly referred to her by her
initials I don't like talking about my
relationships but what I will tell you
about you know CDs she's probably one of
the the greatest human beings I've ever
met
[Music]